congratulations yeah I made it inside
the house you did good
all right this is what's up you can live
here for here you can be pampered with
artists here but if you want to do it
first job now walk to Queens and give me
a sugar cookie sugar cookie man this is
crazy
[Applause]
and she look cookie man look this is not
what I got in the music business to be
doing to be a sugar cookie getter you
know I'm a rapper
who are the five best rappers of all
time think about it
dylon dylon dylon guilin and Dyna
because I spit hot fire so good guys are
fishing there welcome to bad boy it's
bad with baby King stop won't stop
you can y'all first foo do once you turn
daddy out of hit but I need to be a
family you love each other this will
never work
that's right now that's right go out
there and get daddy a hit I'm gonna take
a nap
shut in the studio dad the only way I
could keep the studio open is if y'all
fall out and walk to northern New Jersey
give me a set of left-handed golf glove
I also need you to take a picture with
the midget holdin these balloons take a
picture with the midget holdin these
balloons holdin these balloons you did
it
you went out you found my man you found
a midget man then you got the pictures
you got the golf clubs the keys to the
studio now excuse me I'm going scuba
diving with Chris Tucker an Aquaman
you'd be cool get it
[Music]
y'all not working like a team
I got shut the studio down yo all right
the only way I open the studio up now
Doug I woke up town to the Bronx and get
breast milk from a Cambodian immigrant I
want to drink the finest breast milk
[Applause]
it's 100% Cambodian yeah it's the real
you made my day
[Music]
not only am I gonna open the studio I'm
sending you in there with the legend
that's right Wyclef Playboy disrespect I
wanted to work with Wyclef what I want
to work with puff yeah darling you gotta
get it started
all right I remember a trip this is the
way the dialogue spits you trying to get
some of this hot fire you make this song
or not make this song don't think I want
choke people you can't just choke all
your prop takes hard work if I had my
way I'd never work
stay home all day watch Scarface 50
times eat a turkey sandwich and have sex
all day
then I dress up like a clown and
surprise kid to school then I take the
dump in the back of a movie theater and
just wait somebody Saturday here squish
it's funny to me then I paint read and
play violin I climbed the mountains and
sing the songs that I like to sing I
don't got that kind of time they put
they put
I'm just gonna comb your hair playboy
sorry you just wanna talk up all your
anytime minute this anytime chop onions
right now huh good time to chop onions
you just gonna do your tax's ness is
that what's going on the streets right
now in Texas all right look
I asked some good news and I got some
bad news y'all the bad news is that I'm
shutting down the studio the good news
is that I just saved a lot of money on
my car
[Applause]
Lincoln flatly you can fly I believe so
[Music]
[Applause]